Oh
it's always been around but i think it
was under ronald reagan that it began to
be a sort of serious organization before
that these same people existed but they
weren't politically so well organized
and i think it was under the reagan
administration that they realized that
there was a vast source of voters to tap
into and from the point of view of the
Christians to influence policy
certainly a possibility I don't see it
yet although here and there you do hear
voices now that you haven't heard for a
while making a big point of claiming
that Europe or the West is
judeo-christian which is not something
that was heard very much in the past as
though Jews and Christians were all such
great friends in the building Western
civilization and so in that sense I
think there are signs that it might give
right or religious sentiment but there's
no real proof of it so far
oh there I think various reasons for
that one is that most immigrants from
the Middle East in the United States
tend to be more middle-class better
educated many of them are Christians and
they're not concentrated so much as in
European cities European cities the
Muslim immigrants on the whole are from
village cultures not very well-educated
they como came over as guest workers and
they're very concentrated so if you go
to even private many provincial towns in
countries like the Netherlands you'll
suddenly see a very large number of
people in head scarves and beards and so
on in a way that you don't really see
anywhere in the United States it here
it's just one minority amongst many
well if by conservatives you mean
Christian conservatives I think because
there is a historical antagonism towards
Islam but not it's not necessarily
entirely true that there is no common
ground I think for example when the book
a song on rusty's book was burnt the
were actually conservatives in the West
who had total sympathy with the Muslims
and thought he had it coming and we're
in favor of tightening up blasphemy laws
and so it's not always true that there's
no common ground